adultes enfants familles à l'occasion de
l'inauguration du parcours sportif du
parc de la mgen
ils ont tous participé à un rallye
intergénérationnel le but de l'événement
permettre de créer un véritable vivre
ensemble demande qui a été pris en
compte
il ya trois ans dans les négociations
qui avaient eu pour l'ouverture du parc
en concertation avec les habitants les
habitants souhaité que justement ce beau
parc puissent bénéficier d'un petit
parcours de santé
parce que si vous voulez dans beaucoup
c'est le cas beaucoup de vies à partir
du moment où devant un parc les gens
aiment bien pratiquer une activité
physique et étant donné que la politique
sportive de la municipalité est de
développer le sport un peu partout donc
on a répondu favorablement à son projet
marche à pied course ont encore traction
petits et grands ont pu profiter du
parquet de cette animation pour se
surpasser
un événement qui permet de passer de
bons moments en famille ben c'est vrai
c'est vrai ce n'est pas facile notamment
on avait une petite de 5 ans donc
c'était un peu compliqué pour elle mais
même pour les adultes 1 les traction ou
voilà c'est où les abdos bon genre bien
peu de temps en temps mais sa force
quand même quoi donc ses rêves c'est
vachement intéressant j'ai bien aimé les
saute-mouton les abdos et voilà alors
tais toi le plus compliqué alors
compliqué c'était traction est aussi sat
menton parce qu'il faut se lancer donc
c'est assez compliqué d activité que les
habitants de la verrière pourront
pratiquer toute l'année
désormais le parc de la mgen est ouvert
à tous